u.s president-elect joe biden has chosen
who he wants to run the federal
international aid agency otherwise known
as usaid samantha power previously
served
on the national security council and was
barack obama's u.n
envoy revealing his choice biden
explained why he wants power
on his team sam
is one of our country's most respected
voices on humanitarian issues
and i have seen both her passion and her
principles firsthand
there could be no one no one more
qualified to lead those efforts than
samantha power
well during her previous high-profile
government jobs power has
faced a string of ethical questions from
critics she pushed for
military intervention in libya on
humanitarian grounds during the civil
war there
nearly a decade ago she was also a
strong supporter of u.s involvement in
syria and yemen
both of which have suffered a subsequent
humanitarian crisis
now though she says she is the right
person to lead washington's mission
to improve the world the united states
has a chance to partner with and support
people who are on the front lines in
battling kovid
who are trying to build climate
resilience who are standing up for the
rule of law
standing up against inequality and
trying to create
more just societies humanitarian support
democracy assistance economic
development those are not nice to have
in our foreign policy toolbox they are
critical
former pentagon analyst michael luth
predicts though that the aid agency is
in line
for a major upgrade as a foreign policy
tool
for biden well her position is actually
according to biden is going to be
elevated uh to the national security
council level
so that adds uh gives it added
importance as to how foreign aid
will be used and humanitarian assistance
will be used
as a guiding light of our upcoming
foreign policy under biden
it also shows that we might even go
ahead so far and weaponize it
given samantha power's
previous experience and recommendations
to
then vice president biden and to obama
the president
libya was was one of those outcomes
yemen was another
so if we if we uh need humanitarian
assistance or
uh and and coupled with that would be uh
human rights uh
advocacy and and insistence upon that in
any assistance that we give
does that mean that we're going to go
ahead and shoot it into people's heads
again
so this is a her elevation like this
raises some important questions as to
just to what extent
foreign policy or foreign assistance
will be used
as a foreign policy weapon as opposed to
given
absolute assistance in the future
you